that's the really cool thing about what
what Roz has put on the table it really
gives all of her an opportunity to
examine in totality what he has been
able to accomplish in the two and a half
years that he's been back in Starling
city in his opinion of what they've done
or at least of his work is not very high
so that makes the idea of being the
person that commands the League of
Assassins in any way that he sees fit
makes it really appealing but ultimately
the game that Roz plays with Oliver
throughout the course of the remainder
of our episodes this year really
actually does focus him that force him
to really look within himself and you
know we see a very different Oliver a
more introspective a more vulnerable and
in a lot of ways defeated version of the
character as we move towards the last
portion of our episodes which is fun
because again you can only shut people
out for so long it's been almost three
seasons been like 70 episodes of don't
talk to me and you know you can you can
you can own you you can only stare
broodingly out a window so long my
question is the flash has an incredibly
special family I want to know if you
guys were going to be introducing any
characters such as wally west or bart
allen on the series anytime in the
future yeah that's our hope so and we've
already been picked up for a second year
so
I think we're going to do something like
that we would do it next year hey
youtubers is charlie so Aaron the flash
just did their big PaleyFest panels so
this is going to be an explainer for the
stuff that they talked about like the
really important stuff about you know
the forthcoming season as well as the
next couple of episodes they showed a
couple clips they haven't made of
available online as of the you know me
taping this video when they do I'll do
separate breakdown videos for those so
right off the bat they said a lot of
things that we already know things are
gonna get way darker before they get any
better something really bad is going to
happen to one of the characters in
episode 19 someone might quit the team
someone might die or someone's actually
definitely gonna die Marc Guggenheim did
confirm a character would be dying but
we don't know if it's going to be Roy or
if it's gonna be Quentin or if it's
gonna be masayo son somebody somebody is
going to die that's why I did that
Batman death in the family story
explainer I'll add a link for that in
the description if you guys didn't see
it John Barrowman said a lot of really
interesting things about Merlyn like his
biggest regret is killing the wrong man
remember when he found out that brick
was the man that killed his wife he
thought it was someone else in the
flashbacks they showed him killing that
person he said that's his biggest regret
that he killed the wrong person so if he
could go back in time what would he do
differently he didn't answer it
literally but they will deal with that
in the next couple of episodes he did
confirm that Merlin really loves Thea
and is doing what he thinks is best to
bring her closer to him so it's
completely genuine he's not trying to be
evil about keeping her close I think
that's kind of funny because obviously
what he's doing is really horrible
brainwashing her to kill one of their
best friends will actually explain that
that's going to be a really big part of
her character for the rest of the season
we kind of got a teaser for that in the
last episode where she asked Nyssa to
kill her to take vengeance obviously
that's not gonna happen cuz we saw her
getting her speedy mask like this said
is it's gonna get way darker for all the
characters Oliver I thought this was
interesting Stephen Amell said that
Oliver is really at his weakest right
now he's almost enfeebled I know that
makes a lot of people mad like they want
all over to be really strong he's like
the backbone of the team but he made
this funny comment where he said you can
only stare out a window broodingly for
so long and then like the showrunners
just joked they're like I don't know we
feel like you got a lot more brooding
left in ya they confirmed new people
would learn Oliver's identity and they
actually said the right
ters in the writers room totally love
that trying to explain why no one can
figure out his secret identity when he's
standing right in front of them is a big
trope of the superhero genre so the more
people that find out the happier the
writers are Stephen Amell said something
interesting about racial ghouls offered
him offer to take over the lake he said
that it's not so much an offer as it is
a demand so they're gonna address that
in the next episode like literally next
week we'll find out what that means most
of you probably figured it out if Oliver
turns him down it's going to be dire
consequences for tomorrow if you've ever
seen the batman the animated series
episode they did with racial ghulam
batman demons quest it's kind of like
that so now I'm just gonna like
transition into flash stuff I feel like
just you know in terms of hard specific
details the flash offered up more stuff
during their panel than arrow did so it
was a little bit more fun if you're
looking for new information about the
show this is a real that they showed was
actually from episode 18 the all-star
team up episode the tone is going to
play a lot like the last time felicity
crossed over it'll be mostly humorous
but Felicity's going to get a brand new
villain to fight against like a new
arch-nemesis it'll be Emily Kinney from
the walking dead they gender bent a
villain from the comics she's gonna have
like an army of small bees so Felicity's
gonna have like a hackathon like a
hacker war with her anytime they want to
make a villain for Felicity like they
want to bring someone on for her to
fight they either have to be really
smart or they have to have like really
advanced tech I know a lot of people are
wondering about arrow season 4 there's
been a lot of speculation that Damien
dark from the comics might be the
villain just because they said it's
going to be someone that comes from the
world of tech it's gonna be a genius
character so it'll be someone that
Felicity will be able to help fight more
she's not much used against the League
of Assassins there's not much she can do
when they get into a sword fight so the
solution to bring Felicity back you know
into the arrow cave back with the core
team is to bring a villain that plays
more to her strengths we can talk about
season 4 in the future though they
didn't really spill a lot of season for
details team flash made a whole bunch of
jokes about Harrison wells being the
reverse-flash town Cavanaugh said that
you know there are really two ways you
can play villains and you know obviously
he's doing the really interesting way
you can do like the mustache twirling
villain like you know they're like a
Looney Tunes cartoon or you can play
someone that's a little more emotionally
tied to their characters which is why
when the other characters find out who
Harrison wells is it's going to be much
more rewarding for us as an audience
they did say that
you know because season one has been so
focused on developing Barry Allen as the
flash character season two is where they
might spend some more time developing
caitlin and cisco you know a lot of
powers I know everyone is asking when
they're gonna get their power from the
comics they didn't confirm anything they
didn't say that they would be getting
powers but I think that they're going to
spend more time diving deep into Cisco
and Caitlin in season 2 they made a lot
of jokes about feeding the metahumans
everyone always asked questions about
like where do they go to the bathroom
how do they eat like what happens with
all these prisoners that they capture
Greg Berlanti said that they would
definitely address the ramifications of
team flash playing judge jury and
executioner to all these people I think
that just means prison break I mean I
they're just all going to get out the
end of the season it cause a bunch of
chaos danielle Panabaker joke that they
feed him a lot of belly burgers a lot of
like big belly burgers but someone on
the team does pull duty every once in a
while to like feed them they rotate that
job really cool easter egg Tom Cavanagh
offered up so everyone always wonders
like what all the bumps like the Braille
in his secret room are like the Gideon
Braille he said their production
designer just saw the material and put
it in there but it said it might say
like we validate parking and Braille or
something like that if you read Braille
which I do not you can try to figure out
if it actually says anything I know a
lot of you guys always ask about Wally
West coming on the show they basically
they said last year like before season
one ever aired that they had planned to
do Wally West in the future they just
they never said when I think season two
is kind of like Lee you know maybe like
deep in season two the way they
introduced firestorm because they've
changed a lot about the West family from
the comics what would probably happen is
is it would be a cousin it would be like
irises cousin that would just make him a
little bit more like the new 52 Wally
West and speaking of their family they
actually said that they would explain
what happened to Joe's wife I Iris's
mother in a future episode as for Eddie
Thawne I know everyone's always
wondering about him because they kind of
waited to develop his character like
he's just now getting a lot of good
story the actor said that we would all
be you know really surprised where your
storyline is going I embedding that that
is not going to be true I think there
are a couple clear theories that I've
spelled out and a lot of my videos
across this season he is tied to the
reverse-flash lineage he very clearly is
one of their progenitors as to whether
or not he actually becomes a reverse
flash that remains to be seen there will
be a second reverse flash mark my words
but they won't really
Blaine that till we get into time travel
there was only one thing that bugged me
about the press conference Candace
Patton said this thing about her
character she called herself like a Lois
Lane type character which was she is I
mean she's like a stand-in for Lois Lane
she was trying to compare iris not
knowing who Barry was knowing that he's
the flash to Lois Lane not knowing who's
Superman is the reason that bug me is
because in Man of Steel Lois Lane
totally knows who Clark Kent is she's
like yeah you or that guy that's flying
around helping people she totally tracks
him down it's not like Superman reveals
himself to her she's like yeah I told
him knew who you were there was no
mystery I have a feeling it's gonna go
down the same way with iris like she's
gonna be investigating STAR Labs she'll
catch Barry Allen in a flash type moment
and then be like WTF everyone's been
lying to me they also said they would be
tackling a very notable storyline from
the comics that they have not done
already I think that they were talking
about flashpoint I mean that's just like
one of the clear time travel stories
that they could tell grant gustin teased
it earlier but he had just been
speculating so here's my big question
for you guys if they're gonna tackle a
really quote-unquote big storyline from
the flash comics do you think it's going
to be flashpoint paradox or do you think
it's going to be some other big
storyline remember these are like the
biggest of the big flash storylines and
there's not that many of those in
reference to all that time travel stuff
they did say that the emotional aspects
like the way time-travel effects
characters relationships with each other
is going to be more interesting than
just the flat-out spectacle of time
travel time travels badass but I'm
really interested to see how Eddie
Thawne gets roped into this reverse
flash lore I think you know in terms of
character relationships that's where it
gets really interesting so as soon as
they post those new flash and arrow
clips I'll totally do breakdown videos
be sure to subscribe to get those if you
haven't seen it already I did a
breakdown of the next three episodes
they actually posted an earlier trailer
so you can click here to watch that Mark
Hamill as the trickster that's all say
it's totally amazing and you can click
here to catch up on arrow thanks so much
watching I'll see you guys tonight now
let's all do the thing
you